oh dude just like pick a sport I like
watching NBA some of the best actors
I've ever seen in my entire life flop
game is good is that the new thing now
like like this let's touch him just a
little bit
none of them have the ball and you can
call the foul now yeah I thought you
could suck each other I mean I can't I'm
sorry bro when you when you watch guys
flopping slow-mo that it's just
real worse I hate flopping but I do
respect a guy that could create a flop
to actually get the call the desired
outcome timing everyone's following up
people that draw the fouls against key
players at the right moments those are
game changers yeah yeah that's also like
throwing pepper in someone's eye at the
key moment
also a strategy FIFA started the whole
flopping they're the worst players
everyone's like what like 130 and they
touch each other and they act like it
hurts they get carted off the field and
then like a minute later when the injury
timeout's done they come back you know
what they should do to solve the NBA
flopping if you're cop flopping that's
gonna be your basketball card